president biden's domestic agenda is
getting a big boost from congress last
night the house voted to advance several
of the president's top priorities
including a more than three trillion
dollar budget framework and a voting
rights bill lawmakers also set a date
for a vote on rebuilding the nation's
infrastructure nicole killian is on
capitol hill to unpack it all nicole
good morning hey good morning to you
anthony and that deal almost fell apart
after some resistance from moderate
democrats but for now the president's
build back better agenda appears to be
on track the house approved a three and
a half trillion dollar budget outline
that will be used to craft a broad
package with many of the president's key
initiatives from expanded child care to
education climate change and other
social programs it also sets up a vote
on a trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure bill by september 27th
that was a concession to moderates who
wanted a vote now lawmakers also passed
the john lewis voting rights advancement
act named after the late georgia
congressman the bill would restore
provisions in the 1965 voting rights act
that were struck down by the supreme
court it faces an uphill battle in the
senate where many republican leaders
have expressed opposition as for that
massive budget package democrats hope to
pass it next month alone but some
senators are balking at the price tag
and have threatened not to support it
tony we'll keep tracking it nicole thank
you very much